bercé par les flots de la baie du
bengale c'est un ancien coins de france
logé à l'extrémité de l'inde
un îlot francophone où certains temps
forts de la vie continue d'être célébrée
dans la langue de molière
salut
rajesh et indien lily est française une
nationalité choisi par son grand père au
moment de l'annexion de la colonie au
sous continent
la famille est partie s'installer à
strasbourg mais elle a décidé d'unir
leur petite fille avec un jeune tamoul
les tenues du sud de l'inde mon frère
est sans frais des années 50 alors
c'est pourtant la rencontre
et vous êtes contents oui vraiment lino
6-4 après on a parlé un téléphone après
oui petit à petit on a raconté
rajesh maginot a grandi à pondichéry
acquérir un passeport tricolore c'était
l'espoir de ses parents est le sien
je rêve de la france depuis mon enfance
et maintenant je veux trouver un travail
la barre et rejoindre tous les membres
de ma famille qui sont déjà en métropole
à la mairie les cérémonies sont célébrés
en tamoul mais aussi en langue française
2010 apparaît publiquement la maison
combiner le mariage
[Applaudissements]
d'ici quelques semaines rajesh et lili
s'envoleront pour la capitale alsacienne
comme eux 150 couples mixtes se marient
chaque année dans la ville un chiffre en
augmentation
[Musique]
65 ans après leur attachement à l'union
indienne la france continue de faire
vibrer les coeurs à pondichéry sa
promenade s'est amené en brager et ses
demeures historiques font mémoire de 300
ans de présence coloniale
mais avec l'accroissement de la
population cet héritage culturel est
aujourd'hui en danger
plusieurs amoureux de pondichéry ont
décidé de se battre pour maintenir le
caractère unique de la ville passerelle
entre deux mondes
elle debout
une élève de l'école
angers papa bonjour
bonjour bonjour
à polaires ne parle que quelques mots de
français mais il espère qu'un jour ses
fils pourront faire leurs études
supérieures en métropole ce journaliste
de nationalité indienne a inscrit montée
yosef 6 et 7 ans au lycée français un
effort financier conséquent 1500 euros
par an et par enfant cinq fois plus cher
que l'école en langue anglaise mais
c'est un investissement
mon frère s'est établi en france avec sa
famille donc il pourra prendre soin de
mes enfants s'ils partent étudier là bas
et ça c'est une grande chance pour nous
l'éducation à la française est unique
cela leur donnera un avantage compétitif
important à leur retour en inde tout le
monde dira c'est le docteur français
c'est l'ingénieur français nous aurons
une position sociale supérieure le
français va leur donner de grandes
opportunités
départ en famille sur les chemins de
l'école
le lycée se situe au coeur de la partie
française de pondichéry qu'on appelle
toujours la ville blanche
bonjour
dans quel à un des trois qui viendra
raconter l'histoire est ce qu'il a
compris de l'histoire d'accord
joseph est l'un des seuls élèves de
nationalité indienne here la très grande
majorité des familles sont franco pour
nigérienne mais les parents souvent très
pauvres ne parle pas français
l'hexagone reste le reductil
qui a envie d'aller en france
ou jouets lego de mai
à débloquer comme ça ya donc fort à
faire
mais depuis 10 ans le nombre d'élèves
est en chute libre au lycée de
pondichéry ils ne sont plus que six en
moitié moins qu'il ya 15 ans un paradoxe
qui n'est qu'apparent ans
cette appellation française d'origine
indienne india
temps à disparaître non pas de la
surface de la terre mais de coude chéri
une partie un peu
en france et départ vers la paix entre m
évidemment les
alors
le nombre d'inscrits est encore
important mais les gens reviennent à la
retraite et donc plus en âge
pour compenser les départs le nouveau
proviseur doit convaincre davantage de
familles indiennes d'opter pour l'école
à la française une gageur alors que
l'inde en plein développement économique
utilisent massivement l'anglais l'
influence culturelle de l'ancienne
puissance coloniale recul au moment où
son patrimoine est en péril
tandis shihri possède une concentration
de demeures historiques uniques en inde
1300 bâtiments dont près de 300
constructions coloniales françaises
réparties sur quelques rues leur charme
discret attire toujours plus de
touristes 1 million 400 mille l'an
dernier
[Applaudissements]
ces étudiants en décoration d'intérieur
venu de new delhi ont parcouru plus de
2000 kilomètres pour apprendre le secret
de la rénovation de ces deux meurt sans
plaire
regardez cet ancien bâtiment
administratif rénové par les français
ils ont restauré à l'identique et le
résultat est parfait
j'adore les motifs français les couleurs
des bâtiments ils sont pleins de charme
très accueillants chaleureux
ils font chaud au coeur
je vais certainement reprendre ses
motifs et ses couleurs pour mes projets
futurs
malgré l'argent du tourisme cet héritage
est aujourd'hui en piteux état
80% des demeures historiques ont été
détruites en 25 ans dont de nombreux
bâtiments publics victimes de la
négligence des autorités locales
et voici le symbole de cette incurie
l'ancienne mairie qui s'est effondré en
2014 les anciennes poutres métalliques
vieille de 150 ans jce toujours à terre
c'est un show c'était un bâtiment
symbolique
imaginez six autres mérites village
disparaissait du jour au lendemain mais
ce drame a aussi déclenché un mouvement
populaire une manifestation a réuni des
milliers de personnes à l'époque sur la
promenade et une marche de ou tuant avec
des bougies a été organisée
donc cela en est une prise de conscience
à chocques panda dirige linta qu une
organisation de restauration du
patrimoine présente dans toute l'inde
mais qui ne disposent d'aucune
subvention publique
depuis 30 ans et s'efforce de convaincre
les propriétaires des demeures de
financer une restauration à l'identique
les débuts ont été difficiles
dans les années 70 et 80 légende
démolissez leur maison qu'on bâtira les
bâtiments modernes donc les artisans qui
savez construire annoncés n'étaient au
chômage
on a d'abord dû former des ouvriers maj
anciennes techniques mais le défi était
de leur fournir suffisamment
les terres de ses demeures ne sont pas
nécessairement fortunés
ils vivent dans un bâtiment magnifique
mais ils disent que malheureusement ils
n'ont pas le budget pour restaurer
il existe comme en france une loi qui
protège bâtiment
et donc des avantages financiers fiscaux
aux propriétaires qui n'ont pas les
moyens
depuis cinq ans le rythme des
rénovations s'est accélérée à chocques
panda dirige une dizaine de chantiers
dans la ville et en trente ans il a
resterait une centaine de demeures
historiques dans le quartier français
comme lui plusieurs habitants une oeuvre
pour enrayer le déclin de la présence
française à pondichéry
dans cette demeure historique du
quartier tamouls ville rejeton de l'une
des plus vieilles familles franco
pondichéry yens de la ville le père de
jean piat gnanou était bijoutier son
père fonctionnaire de l'administration
coloniale a choisi la nationalité
française pour lui et pour ses sept
enfants
tout le monde a fait ses études en inde
et à l'âge adulte tout le monde a quitté
l'aim pour partir en france pour pouvoir
travailler et ils ont tous vécu en
france avec leurs enfants leurs
petits-enfants maintenant et moi j'ai
quitté l'inde à présent où il a commencé
à travailler avec justin enfance jusqu'à
l'âge de 30 ans et on a décidé ont
donnée de revenir en inde on savait pas
dans quel but avec quel projet à son
retour en 2008 le diplômé d'école de
commerce fonde une agence de voyages
jean piat gnanou crée ensuite deux
autres entreprises dans le textile et la
menuiserie mais le plus grand pari de ce
bourreau de travail c'est la
transformation de cette ancienne maison
familiale en un hôtel de luxe avec le
concours d'architectes français
mélange de matériaux anciens et modernes
piscine à laitages chambres design épuré
à 200 euros la nuit et une cuisine
franco indienne sophistiqués l'objectif
est d'attirer une clientèle
internationale et indiennes fortunés
l'idée c'est que voilà c'est une vieille
bâtisse coloniale
il y avait du potentiel à travailler
dessus et
et on a on a mûri le projet en passant
de ça les architectes ont voulu garder
vraiment la même disposition sans rien
changer de rez-de-chaussée lagarde est
en fait la peinture d'origine et on la
construit au dessus
le premier étage est le deuxième étage
par la suite
depuis son ouverture en 2014 après
quatre années de travaux l'hôtel affiche
complet ce succès a permis à jean piat à
nous de conserver le patrimoine familial
tout en investissant dans l'avenir
il lance aujourd'hui un appel alors que
la population française de la ville a
diminué de 80% en quelques décennies
germain est telle qu'on ne fait rien
reviennent sur qu'on dit cherry pas
après leur retraite mais pour faire leur
vie parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses à faire sur qu'on dit
cherry sur l'inde et c'est le moment de
venir il faut que les fonds cocon
ligériens pense vraiment à
ascq ont légué leurs parents et essayer
de conserver les bâtiments même si c'est
des bâtiments neufs mais d'arrêter de
les vendre ce cas la force de les vendre
comme je les dis pondichéry va se vider
de pondichéry rien
ne plus conjuguer seulement pondichéry
et la france au passé c'est l'ambition
d'une nouvelle génération
c'est aussi l'objectif d'un vaste
programme de rénovation de la ville
le projet smart city ville intelligente
en anglais mené par le gouvernement
indien 100 millions d'euros qui vont
être dépensées pour moderniser les
infrastructures et le patrimoine
architectural
la france s'est engagée à financer un
tiers de la somme et à détacher un
architecte des bâtiments de france pour
assister l'administration indienne ces
infrastructures ont été mises en place
au 19e siècle par les ingénieurs
français et les ingénieurs indiens
qui était présent et elles ont été
toutes ces infrastructures dimensionné
pour une ville de 60 mille habitants
aujourd'hui on a une ville une
agglomération de sept cent mille
habitants et on a des infrastructures
qui sont insuffisamment dimensionné
ce projet de smart city est une
opportunité unique pour renforcer la
relation entre la france et pour nous
au fil des années cette influence de la
france a diminué c'est dommage car je
pense que la france peut apporter une
grande expertise tombons nigeria besoin
les premiers signes du changement sont
visibles les habitants retrouvent leurs
plages et la promenade est en train
d'être rallongée
lentement mais sûrement pondichéry ouvre
un nouveau chapitre de son histoire avec
commis hier un parfum de france